Curren this sort of stuff just gets
weird sometimes before I get into what
this video is actually about I'm just
gonna say this once for the record so
that people won't ask they're gonna ask
anyways but just so it's out there yes
I've seen the new trailer for Luke Cage
no I'm not gonna do another video on it
it makes me feel slightly better than
the first trailer did I like how much
emphasis Mariah gets in it I don't like
that it still looks like there she's
gonna be somewhat undercut by bushmaster
but it does look like she is going to be
fairly prominent is gonna be still be
trying to take advantage of the
situation that's great the fact that she
should have taken over the second half
of the show is said they gave her the
diamond back really tick me off in the
first season so it's a step up from the
trailer but my feelings haven't changed
enough that it's worth a whole new video
there we go so Matthew Vaughn a director
who until recently I would have said
hadn't made a bad film if you know if
you don't know Matthew Vaughn by name
going back a ways he did layer-cake he
did Stardust what he is best known for
though it would be things like x-men
first class kick-ass Kingsman the Secret
Service both of them would be sequel
being what I would consider to be his
first genuinely bad movie so he he
talked to Empire and he has indicated a
couple things about what he's working on
right now and whether or not he's
intending to direct these or these are
simply things being shepherded through
his studio Marv yes the man has studio
called Marv I don't know but he he's
working on apparently some form of
reboot for kick-ass and then a third
Kingsman film a I don't even want to
call it a Kingsman prequel I think they
called it a spinoff set in like the
early 1900s
so like earlier days of the King's Men
as an organ
nation and also potentially a TV series
though I couldn't gather from the Empire
piece whether or not it that was
intended to carry over any characters
from the TV show or not actually whether
it's intended to be in continuity out of
continuity a different take no idea but
this kind of all surprised me largely
because prior to King's Men the Golden
Circle
Matthew Vaughn didn't do sequels not as
a director at any rate I mean he
produced kick-ass too but it directed so
looking to just start basically
wallowing in established properties and
ones of I mean let's just be blunt about
it questionable value is a little odd
and when I say questionable value I mean
in both the cases of kick-ass and
Kingsman their first films did way
better than anyone expected and their
second films did slightly better than
broke even basically that like how big
they were relative to their budget went
down in both cases so it's odd that he's
putting so much focus here I have a
suspicion as to why and I don't know if
I'm the only one connecting these dots I
didn't see anyone else mentioned this in
write-ups but I also didn't dig that
much I don't I research and I we we try
and you know 50-foot radius so I think
what might be going on is we might be
looking at something similar to the Fox
Marvel situation and I'm talking about
prior to the supposed buyout merger
thing that's still in the works and not
a done deal
we'll see if Comcast moves in on that or
whatever and by that I mean you know
part of the reason why geeks like me got
very either excited or interested in
what was gonna happen with the potential
of Disney acquiring Fox was because Fox
had some of the some of the Marvel
properties they had licensed x-men
Fantastic Four daredevil
prior to Marvel starting to actually
produce their own films they license the
movie rice all those things ahead of
2008 Iron Man so they got to keep
retaining those rights as long as they
continued to make movies about them
that's why we have that horrible
Fantastic Four reboot and that's also
why Marvel got daredevil back because
Fox ran out the clock
they didn't started they didn't get a
new project shooting and the rights
reverted I suspect we're looking at a
similar situation with the kick-ass and
Kingsman properties with Marv having
that's so weird to say having the movie
rights because Millar world Mark
Millar's company because Mark Millar is
the originator of both those properties
because both kick ass and Kingsman were
originally comic books both of which
were written by Mark Millar I've heard
I'm probably gonna end up keep saying
Millar it might just be pronounced
Miller I can I don't know I'm sure
people will correct me that's how I'm
gonna save for this video all right
so Mark Millar's company Millar world
was complete was acquired in its
entirety by Netflix that happened last
year and Netflix has started developing
projects based around that and based on
his properties now that would have
included Kingsman and kick-ass now
before anyone brings up yes Kingsman and
kick-ass were both published through
Marvel but they were published through
Marvel's creator owned brand I believe
whose icon so Millar has actually
retained the rights to those even though
they were published through a Marvel
they were never Marvel Marvel properties
Marvel never had the rights to those
themselves so those should have been
part of the Millar world deal but they
wouldn't have been because those rights
specifically had already gone to Matthew
Vaughn and I
have to wonder if what is driving him to
dig into these franchises more is
because if he doesn't the rights are
gonna revert back and there might have
been some kind of you know time to
clause you know anyway but he probably
wasn't competing with anybody for the
for the right he probably I mean he
seemed to have a really good
relationship
Matthew Vaughn and Mark Millar so you
you get the impression that you know he
probably would have been happening in
Millar probably would have been happy to
you know renew the contract with Vaughn
Netflix won't want to do that they'll
want the rights back so they can do
their own thing with it since those are
the two it's you know established as
film franchises that that they could
possibly have out of this deal and if
that is the motivation and I hope it's
not it but it it feels like it is and it
makes me really nervous for what Matthew
Vaughn's gonna do with the rest of his
career because I had fat I really felt
basically until Kingsman to that he was
a director to keep an eye on and I
understand there's the stability of
having control of an own franchise that
makes money even though and you know in
the case of the sequels it's a reduced
amounts of money like that the King
counts one really puzzles me or at least
to a degree like cuz that they'd have to
flat-out reboot which is what they're
talking about because the part of the
part of the appeal of kick-ass is how
young these people are especially
someone like a girl and all the actors
have aged out of the parts or at least
aged out of where yo the hook is still
relevant so they're already talking to
reboot they're talking possible spin-off
just for a hit girl alone maybe an
origin story with her and Big Daddy who
was played by Nicolas Cage in that film
and like I'm not saying there's no good
material to be mucked out of this but it
does feel like that it does feel like
milking the property as opposed to
something that you do because yeah
that's something definitely that we need
to do
that's the story needs to be told which
is how I have on had always come across
me as a filmmaker prior to that but I
think he has started settling into the
stability of franchises and especially
with how much he's trying to get lined
up to keep moving forward with Kingsman
material which I woke a year ago I would
have been really enthusiastic of about
but I had a lot of problems with
Kingsman the Golden Circle when I saw it
and the more time has gone on the bigger
those problems have become I actually
kind of hate it now I think it's right
up there with men in black - for sequels
that do legitimate damage to the
franchise potential of the property so I
mean part of the reason I'm making this
video is because honestly I might never
want to talk about what Matthew Vaughn
is up to again I mean when trailers
start coming out for this stuff maybe I
will but like this makes me not want to
talk about the guy what he's up to and
that bums me out because he wasn't he
was a director who really excited me for
a long time I mean when you go from you
know something as gritty and and Guy
Ritchie asked which is fitting because
Vaughan used to produce Guy Ritchie
movies back in the day but as layer cake
and then go to something as fantastical
as Stardust and then to you know be
willing to dabble in an established
franchise was something like x-men first
class and you know he he really showed
what seemed to be a breath of interest
and now he's just narrowed in on these
two franchises which neither of which
are franchises I'd be that interested in
seeing continued and if I'm right about
the motivation for why he's pushing
these two I'm starting to wonder if the
creative spark is kind of going out
that's me
projecting a bit and that's probably an
overstatement
that's probably unfair but
I think they can't happen especially
when somebody gets saddled with more or
less obligatory stuff I think that's
happened to Peter Jackson if I'm being
honest I know I'm hoping he gets a
project that reignites his fire soon but
and I'm really worried that the same
things gonna happen to Matthew Vaughn
so yeah continuations reboots spin-offs
whatever for kick ass and Kingsman and
possibly that being all Matthew Vaughn's
going to do for the first foreseeable
future what are your thoughts about it
are they as cynical as mine are you more
optimistic well whatever they are drop
something out in the comments let's talk
about it
there's all the stuff to do there's a
whole list of links down there Twitter
and patreon and place you can get
t-shirts etc links for all that stuff
and more is down in the description so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]